und wann kommt der teil wo wir mit dem
filzstiften schnäuzer malen
das gibt's nicht das macht man dann erst
wenn die hängen
politikberater johannes hillje
analysiert für uns die kampagnen der
parteien
wenn du nicht gerade am fenster steht
und in die ferne schaut herr hille was
macht ein erfolgreiches wahlplakat aus
auf wahlplakaten ist nicht viel platz
für inhalt also es muss eine klare
eindeutige botschaft sein und in der
regel wird ja auch nur ein thema auf
einem wahlplakat behandelt und dazu wird
dann ganz klar gesagt was man für eine
position zu dem thema hat wenn sie sich
die aktuellen kampagnen so angucken wer
überzeugt wieder am meisten
so schlecht sind die alle
wahlkampf das ist oft sex und
rock'n'roll oder halb acht uhr morgens
uckermark plakate kleben mit dem grünen
was machen wir jetzt genau genau also
wir haben zwei unterschiedliche art von
plakaten wir haben einmal
sind sie quasi pappe parkkarte die
komplett fertig selbst nicht nur vorne
und wir haben aber noch unten ganz viele
von den alten packung stehen hier findet
man hier ja und die werden wir noch mal
selber kleister und deshalb noch mal
deutlich ökologischer und nachhaltiger
thema recycling ist ja eigentlich ein
grünes thema können wir nicht die
einfach noch mal nehmen hallo tschüss
hast das ist einfach nicht mehr aktuell
oder doch das wäre noch aktuell so man
hätte es auch nochmal nehmen können ist
ja vielleicht noch mal eine gute unter
diskussionspunkt unseren vorstand findet
halt einfach noch um einige wochen nicht
da habe ich schon geholfen
sind denn in zeiten von social media
wahlplakat überhaupt noch zeitgemäß also
niemand wird seine wahlentscheidung von
dem wahlplakat abhängig machen aber es
ist tut mir leid wenn ich die illusion
hier jetzt zerstöre aber es signalisiert
den menschen es findet eine wahl statt
und das sind die kandidaten die zur wahl
stehen nutzen will seit den 80ern nur
nach den wahlplakaten in seiner straße
sie nehmen das schönste ja wirtschaft
und klima ohne krise was sagen sie dazu
na gut es
halt auch so ein klassischer wahlspruch
eine wirtschaft und klima ohne krise
also über finden sie nicht klimaschutz
wichtig da im klimaschutz wichtig
wirtschaft auch aber da könnte auch
draufstehen zukunft für die auch wichtig
[Musik]
[Applaus]
er ist das erste mal ich hab natürlich
auch eigene plakate auf vorbereitet bin
nicht überrascht ja ja
das heißt sie hiervon
ich habe nicht gesagt wer kann schon
auch das für für das ist echt diese form
für plakate ist echt schlecht
fahrradfahrern bundestagswahl 2021 oder
wie habe ja gesagt generalprobe also ich
glaube ich glaube wir wir gehen noch mal
zurück und machen das aber mit dem
kleist oder haben sie mal wir können das
hier auch so durch pressen und nein sie
sich kaputt da haben sie aber schon ganz
schön mühe geben beim foto raussuchen
oder man muss ja einfach nur auf google
bildersuche es gibt ja nur solche bilder
von robert habeck es gibt ja kein bild
wo robert habeck nicht irgendwie am
strand steht barfuß im watt und posiert
die spd ist ja sehr gelobt wurde für
ihre kampagne ist das nicht irgendwie
blöd jetzt unter dem gelobten spd plakat
zu hängen auch da habe ich dass da jetzt
hier einfach grün und rot das ist doch
gar nicht so schlecht wie gemeinsam
altana oder wir kommen zur spd da haben
wir einmal respekt für dich olaf scholz
ja olaf scholz stellt man hier eindeutig
in den vordergrund das ist sozusagen das
was womit man überzeugen will und lustig
ist so ein bisschen auch hier wieder
dieses retro design also das rote im
hintergrund aber endlich bekennt sich
die spd wieder zum rot man hat ja auch
schon in anderen wahlkämpfen sich vom
rot verabschiedet und mit anderen farben
experimentiert dann haben wir natürlich
auch noch eigene spd plakat genau und
zwar olaf scholz er ist weder laschet
noch baerbock
wie finden sie es er ist so ein bisschen
die botschaft mit mir wird weniger
schlimm
die anderen machen die anderen machen
die fehler ich mache keine
wir sind nicht nur bei den grünen
sondern auch im willy brandt haus wo
schon viele siege gefeiert wurden also
das hat mir zumindest lutz erzählt was
ist denn wichtig also wahlplakaten
dass die plakativ sind und so sind wir
wieder zur rückbesinnung der farbe rot
gekommen wir haben es reduziert
eigentlich nicht wir sind ganz banal
name botschaft foto farbe also ich komme
aus einem drucker familie also und da
weiß ich also ein farbton wenn man nur
mit einem farbton druckt es halt auch
viel billiger
historisch gesehen ist das so ja aber
wenn plakate auffallen sollen war das
dann erst mal eine herausforderung dass
olaf scholz nicht der auffallendste
mensch jemand weiß man es ist ein
standbild oder bewegtbild bei urlaub im
plakat ist das meist bestand bild ist
richtig dass das ist eine eselsbrücke
und die so kann man sich dann merken was
kostet denn so eine kampagne unser
wahlkampf kostet circa 15 millionen also
das ist aber alles na also das fängt an
bei dem fotoshooting geht hin bis zu den
großveranstaltungen divers machen also
ihr wahlkampf kostet 15 millionen
ungefähr wie viel hat er letztes mal
gekauft 25
und wie viele stimmen hat er letzte mal
gekostet das weiß ich nicht ich mache
jetzt diesen wahlkampf aber dadurch dass
wir jetzt ein rot machen bei den
plakaten sparen wir da ja sehr viel geld
ein können sie uns denn versprechen dass
die spd nicht wieder eine groko geht
also wenn wir jetzt fleißig das mit den
stimmen kriegen dann ist das unser ziel
wir wollen
einfach ganz klar dass vier jahren wir
haben soviel getan von der heute show
heute schon der brotzeit endet
[Musik]
dann erst mal pro
schuss
naja das sagen sie immer mit hafer mich
da steht sie ja ja das ist ja wirklich
klischee grüne herz hier wahnsinn wie
die das im internet machen oder immer
auf der jagd nach dem nächsten like nach
den nächsten wählerstimme richtig
unangenehm
naja wenn euch das video gefallen hat
dann lass doch ein leichter und mit der
zweitstimme könnt ihr auch noch den
kanal abonnieren